شرع الامريكيون في التصويت في انتخابات
التجديد النصفي للكونغرس في ظل توقعات
بحصول الجمهوريين على غالبيه المقاعد
تتصاعد الاسئله بشان تاثير النتائج
المحتمله على سياسات واشنطن في ملفات
دوليه من اهمها الحرب في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الجديده
بحق البيت الابيض وسياساته تحت الاداره
الديمقراطيه ورقم الاهميه التقليديه
للمشاغل الداخليه فان الجدل حول الموقف
والدوري الامريكي في الحرب بين روسيا
واوكرانيا قد فرض نفس وفي ظل فرضيه ان
يحرز الجمهوريون تقدما في هذه المنزله
الانتخابيه يؤكد يعارفون بمطبخ القرار
السياسي في الولايات المتحده ان صلاحيات
الواسعه التي يتمتع بها الرئيس في مجال
السياسه الخارجيه لا تمنع الجمهوريين من
عرقله سياساته بحسب التمويل في مجلس
النواب او رفض التصديق على اي معاهدات في
مجلس الشيوخ وذلك ما يتطلب سيطره منهم على
غرفتي
بمناقشه هذا موضوع معنا الدكتور جيمس
روبنز كبير باحثين في المجلس الامريكي
للسياسه الخارجيه والمسؤول السابق في
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه وجون روبن محلل
الجزيره لشؤون الانتخابات النصفيه
والمساعده السابق لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي
وينضم الينا كذلك في الاستديو الدكتور
خليل العناني محلل الجزيره لشؤون
الانتخابات المصريه والاستاد العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه اهلا وسهلا
بكم جميعا من اين تريدون ان تبدوا
اوكرانيا وسوف اخذ وجهه النظر الديمقراطيه
والجمهوريه اذا ما فاز الجمهوريون او
الديمقراطيون كيف يمكن ان يتاثر هذا الملف
والسياسه الخارجيه لاداره الرئيس
يسعدني ان اكون معكم هنا عندما يتدخل
الكونجرس لديه صلاحيه قويه وهي مرتبطه
بالاموال بالنسبه الى اوكرانيا السياسه
العامه في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تقضي بدعم اوكرانيا بشكل واسع نطاق ولكن
الشيطان يكمن بالتفاصيل بالتفاصيل الاموال
حتى الان الدعم العسكري والدعم
الاقتصادي لاوكرانيا قضيه بدعم الحزبين
ولكن بالنسبه الى الجمهوريين سوف يركزون
على ان الدعم لافغانستان
مضرا وسوف يحاولون ان يقود الدعم ل همم
اوكرانيا ولذلك نحن سوف نشاهد اداره
في محاوله منها لكي تخفف من تاثير
الجمهوريين على هذا الموضوع
دكتور جيمز ماذا سيفعل الجمهوريون اذا
تمكنوا من السيطره على الكونجرس ومجلس
الشيوخ
فيما يخص الحب اوكرانيا طبعا
حول ما قيل هناك نقاش بنسبه الى هذا
الموضوع حتى اللحظه الراهنه موضوع
اوكرانيا
الحزبين ولكن سوف يتم ضبط الانفاق ولكن
الانفاق سوف يستمر ثلث الحزب الجمهوريه
يسحب هذا الدعاء والبعض التقدمين
الديمقراطيين وهم اقليه سوف يعبرون عن
رايهم ولكن اعتقد ان الوسط هو من سوف يحكم
بقياده الرئيس سوف تحظى اوكرانيا لبعض
الدعم من الولايات المتحده
ولكنها ليس هذا ما نسمعه الان الاصوات
تتحدث عن ان يعني ربما يجب ان يتقلص الدعم
لاوكرانيا خاصه في الجانب الجمهوري
ان اكثر الناس الذين عبروا عن هذا الموضوع
هم من الجمهوريين ولكن اذا ما اضفنا
الاصوات نرى بعض المعارضه غير ان هناك
جهود على مستوى الجمهوريين بالاضافه الى
الديمقراطيه طبعا الجمهوريون ليس بصفه
عاطيهم ان يوقفوا كل الدعامه اذا ما اضفنا
اصوات الوسط في الحزبين اعتقدوا ان
الاكثريه في الحسبان لا تزال تدعم
اوكرانيا هناك بعض المناقشات قد تقطع بعض
المبالغ ولكن اعتقد ان الدعم سوف يكون
قائمه
دكتور خليل اذا هذا ياتي فقط في سياق
الحملات الانتخابيه ولكن في الحقيقه
لاهميه الامن القومي سيعمل الجانبان معا
لتوفير الدعم لاوكرانيا هكذا ترى
امريكي
وعسكريا لماذا لان هناك قناه امريكيه من
الحرب بين روسيا اوكرانيا هي بين حرب بين
روسيا والغرب وهناك حاجه امريكيه لطمئنه
الغرب خاصه الحلفاء الاوروبيين بان هناك
دعم امريكي متواصل فيما يتعلم هذه المساله
الامر متعلق باستخدام هذه المساله في
الصراع الانتخابي ولكن اعتقد ان هناك
امرين على الاقل سوف يتم اعاده النظر
فيهما اول امر متعلق بان لا يكون الدعم
الاوكرانيا كانه شيك على بياض او دعم او
حساب مفتوح بدون قيود بدون سقف الكونجرس
بالفعل وافق تمايل الماضي على ميزانيه
حوالي 40 مليار دولار لدعم اوكراني عسكريه
واقتصاديه والصرف منها على الاقل حتى هذه
اللحظه 17 مليار مليار دولار فاول نقطه
تتم يعني حتى يكون شيك على بياض وتكون
حارب مفتوحه متعلق بالضغط من اجل التواصل
لاتفاق او لمفاوضات هناك الان حديث على
مستوى سواء من خلال مستشار الامير مقام
الامام الامريكي جاكسون او من خلال انتر
بلينك وزير الخارجيه حول الضغط على
اوكرانيا كي تفتح المجال لمفاوضات نجل
انهاء الصراحه وهذا يعني ان هناك تملم
الامريكي داخلي ان تكون هذه الحرب حرب حرب
بلا نهايه حرب بلا افوق حرب بلا حدود
وبالتالي اعتقد انه سيكون هناك اعاده نظر
في امكانيه التوصل لاتفاق ينهي الحرب باي
شكل من الاشكال قبل ان ينتقل الى ملف اخر
جويل تودد التعليق على ما سر من ان الرئيس
بيضا نحتد في في مكالمه مع زلينسكي لانه
راى انه لم يكن ممتنا بما يكفي لي الدعم
الامريكي
في الحقيقه
رئيس الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في مرحله
ما يقول نحن ندعم اوكرانيا ندعم سياده
اوكرانيا وحده اراضي اوكرانيا ولكن يجب ان
تتصرف بطريقه مسؤوله وكما قال خليل انا
اتفق مع هناك
موظفين اساسيين على مستوى الامن القومي
يحاولون ان يعملوا على الفرص الدبلوماسيه
وكيفيه تحريك رئيس بلنسكي بهذا الاتجاه من
دون الضغط عليه بشكل كبير هذا الاتجاه
نراه في الحزب الجمهوري يودون ان يكون همم
ضاغطا بشكل اكبر بنسبه الى لديه خبره في
سياسه الخارجيه العلاقات الدوليه يوضح
الصوره ولكن لديه علاقه قويه مع رئيس كده
ننتقل الى ملف اخر موضوع
افغانستان كيف يمكن ان يتاثر في حاله فوز
الديمقراطيين او الجمهوريه
بلاك هول او عباره عن ثقب الاسود يبتلع كل
شيء وبالتالي انهاء الحرب الامريكيه لكن
المشكله الرئيسيه عثمان في كيفيه تنفيذ
ذلك ما حدث خلال اغسطس 20 21 كان هناك كان
هناك كان سحابا فوضيا لحد بعيد تم معركه
المستوى المستوى الاول هو انه على ما يبدو
انه تنسيق امريكي اوروبي او امريكي
المساله وبالتالي كان هناك نوع من الفوضى
عدم احترام هذه المساله الامر الثاني
المتعلق بتاثير ذلك على صفحه امريكا
باعتبارها حديث موثوق به راينا وسمعنا
اكثر من مره انه انسحاب من افغانستان اعطى
اشاره لخلفاء امريكا في المنطقه العربيه
خاصه في الخليج العربي بانها حليف غير
منطقه في اي وقت تترك البلد بدون اي نوع
من الدفاع عنها وبالتالي انا اعتقد انه صح
هناك اتفاق على الاصحابنا في افغانستان
لكن ايضا هناك محاوله لرد على اي تاريخ قد
ياتي من افغانستان وراه اين في اختلال
ايمن الظاهري هذا التزام امريكي بغض النظر
عن الحزب الذي يحكم سواء جمهور قدام مساله
تكاد تكون على اتفاق او اجماع في الامم
الامريكيه انه حد عاقيه تهديئه امريكا من
افغانستان في العالم دكتور جيمس بالنسبه
الافغانستان الى اين يمكن ان تتجهله
الامور
في حال فوز الجمهوريه
الجمهوريين بنسبه الى موضوع افغانستان سوف
يقومون بتحليلي الازمه التي حصلت وسوف
يصعبون الامور على الرئيس هو موضوع
السياسي اما بالنسبه الى الديمقراطيين سوف
يصلون الضوء على ان الرئيس ترامب هو الذي
تحدث عن الانسحاب وبعض نفذ خطه ترامب ولكن
اعتقده اننا سوف نرى سلسله من جلسات
الاستماع بتنظيم من الجمهوريين لاعاده
التطرق الى هذا الكابوس بنسبه الى
الديمقراطيين حيث ان معدلات الدعم تراجعت
بهذا الخصوص وذلك بهدف احراج الرئيس
اذا سوف يكون جزءا من صداعا كبير للرئيس
بايدينا اذا فاز الجمهوريون خاصه في مجلس
الشيوخ
يا اهل سوريا
عندما عملته في وزاره الخارجيه كنت
المسؤول كبير مسؤوليه للحزب الديمقراطي
وتعاملته مع
مجلس النواب بقياده الجمهوريه وهم يبلون
بلاءا حسنا بالتركيز على نقاط تفصيليه
قاموا بذلك بنفس الطريقه بالنسبه الى
بنغازي ويمكننا ان نرى نفس الشيء بالنسبه
الى افغانستان
الذين قتلوا في عمليه الاجلاء التي حصلت
اذا هناك الكثير بنسبه الى موضوع
افغانستان الذي سوف يحاول الجمهوريون ان
يستغلوه وهم يعرفون ان الرئيس ترامب اراد
ان يخرج من افغانستان ولكن الحجه سوف تركز
على قدره الرئيس على القياده وهذا مكمل
الخطر
موضوع كهذا اذا لا يتم التعامل معه على ان
له علاقه بمصالح استراتيجيه للولايات
المتحده ولكن يستخدم سياسيا من الحزبين ان
ان هذا ما فهمته من اجابه صديقي هنا اهل
جانب الاخر
اثناء موسم انتخابي كل شيء هو عباره عن
مجال المزايده والتنافس الانتخابي سواء
الانتخابات نعم نعم
جزء من مظله كبيره اسمها الحرب على
الارهاب وبالتالي اي اداره تاتي سواء كان
كونجرس سواء كان رئيس سواء كان الخارجيه
الامريكيه بتاعنا من خلال المصلحه
الامريكيه العليا لامن قوله لامريكا
وبالتالي حتى لو فاز الجمهوريون
بالانتخابات لن يتغير فيما يتعلق بسافر
الامريكي لكن ايضا قد تستخدم كما قال
الزمن الجمهوري داخليا لماذا للضغط على
بايدي وقدره حتى استبواب او حتى ربما
محاوله
نظام استبعاده لكنه وارد جدا في ايطاليا
السياسيه بين الديمقراطين والجمهوريين ان
يتم التركيز على هذه المساله كما قال جويل
قليل حكم حدث مع بنغازي استخدام ما كاداء
او غرق سحربه في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
المقبله انه مساحات كانت سحاب الفضائيه
لاسا باعتراف الجمهوريه بل اعتراف كبار
القدر العسكريين في اداره بيض نفسها قالوا
نحن لم نكن مستعجنه بشكل الكافي نعم الذي
اقر الخروج كان كانت ترامب ولكن الذي نفذ
وكلامين كان بايدي وبالتالي هناك استغلال
سياسي بلا شك لكل اخطاء الاداره فيما
يتعلق بالمزاده السياسيه والانتخابات
الداخليه همم ايران ما الذي سوف يحدث بشان
ايران يعني انسحب الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب من همم من الاتفاق معه ايران
يفترض انه سيعود الديمقراطيون الى هذا
الاتفاق هذا لا يتم لم يتم همم بعد ابدا
بكالوريا
ما الذي تتوقعه في كلاسيناريوهين فوز
الجمهوريين او الديمقراطيه
في المرحله الراهنه اداره الرئيس تغيروا
في خطابها تقول الولايات المتحده تقف الى
جانب الشعب الايراني في مظاهراته للدفاع
عن حقوق الانسان وحقوق المراه وتبقى
الفرصه سانحه للدبلوماسيه نحن جميعنا نعرف
ان الطريقه الوحيده لمنع ايران من
الاستحواذ على القنبله النوويه هي من خلال
الاتفاق دونالد ترامب ترك هذا الاتفاق
وهدد المنطقه وهناك قلق في المنطقه اذا
توقعات ايران او طموحات ايران اذا سوف يتم
التركيز على الشعب الايراني وتفادي كل
المساله النوويه الرئيس
لديه السلطه وصلاحيه واسعه للتفاوض بشان
هذا الاتفاق وسوف يحظى بدعم الديمقراطيين
في حاله تمكن من ذلك
ولكن ماذا عن الجمهوريين كوثر كيف
سيتعاملون مع هذا الملف
اداره اوباما حاولت ان تبني اتفاق النوويه
مع ايران بشكل لا يحضر باشراف الكونجرس او
صدقه المجلس الشيوخ اذا النظريا الكونجرس
ليس لديه دور ولكن يمكن ان تجري جلسات
استماع ويمكن رفع الصوت للمراجعه اعتقد ان
الجمهوريين سوف يضغطون ضد اي اتفاق النووي
مع ايران واي اتفاق لا يتضمن برنامج ايران
النووي وحقوق الانسان ودعم الارهاب وهي
مساء اليركز عليها الحزب الجمهوريه ونعم
سوف يتم التركيز بشكل كبير على حقوق
الانسان حقوق المراه والقمع الذي يجري
حاليا في ايران
دكتور خليل هل ترى ان هناك فرق كبير بين
وجهتي النظر او على الاقل من الناحيه
العمليه في التعامل مع هذا الملف لانه
الديمقراطين في نهايه المطاف لم يعودوا
الى الاتفاق كما كان يرغب الايراني هذا
صحيح هناك هناك فرق كبير طبعا عثمان لماذا
لانه همم بايضا عندما جاء السلطه جاء من
خلال وعود كثيره جدا من ضمنها التوصل
اعاده تفعيل اتفاق القديم بتاع 2015 طبعا
اعترض عليه الجمهوريين قبل ذلك وبالتالي
هو يثوب ذلك باعتباره انجاز في السياسه
الخارجيه الامريكيه حتى هذه اللحظه هذا
الانجاز المتعثر لماذا هناك هل هناك عطف
في مفاوضات غير مباشر للطرفين ايران وبين
امريكا وبالتالي هناك امكانيه ذلك
السياسيه مقابل الجمهوريين لو فات
الجمهوريين بالكونكريز الخاص بمجلس الشيوخ
اعتقد هناك صعوبه في ذلك طبعا صلاحيات
الرئيس انور ان يوقع اتفاق كما يشاء لكن
من الصعب الالتزام به خارجيه وهذا احد
شروط ايران انه ان ان تطالب ان هناك
التزام امريكي بقى لا تنسحب اداره امريكيه
مقبله من اي اتفاق مع حدث مع ترامب عندما
انسحب في 2018 وبالتالي في حال فوه
كورتيون بمجلس النواب ابو مجلس الشيوخ
الاثنين مع بعض يعني الكونجرس نحن ازاء
يعني خيار قد يكون ايسر واسهل مما لافذ
الجمهوريين بدالك
اذا فاز الديموقراطيون يعني خيار التوسل
اتفاق مع ايران قد يكون اسهل من في حاله
وجود الجمهوريين باعتبارهم انهم فائزين
في الحقيقه لماذا لم يعد الديمقراطيون الى
همم الاتفاق لان هذا ما كان يطالب به
الايرانيون انتم من سحبتم لم ننسحب لماذا
لا تعبدون الارتفاع ويكون كل طرف ملزما
بان يلتزم بما وقع عليه
العوده
انها لم تنتهي هناك احباطن على مستوى
اوروبا حتى اذاعه ايران ببعض اوجه هي هذه
المفاوضات ونحن نتحدث عن امتثال مقابل
امتثال العوده الى الاتصال وايران تلتزم
بالمقابل بوضع حدن للبرنامج النووي وفقا
للاتفاق ولكن خليل على حق هذا وعد اطلقه
الرئيس ايضا في حملته وهي اولويه في
السياسه الخارجيه الديمقراطيه ما من بديل
عن اتفاق ممنعه السلاح النووي في ايران
هناك امكانيه بالنسبه الى ايران في نهايه
هذا العام لكي تطور على انجح قنبله او
اكثر لذلك الامر ملف نحن لسنا بحاجه الى
ازمه نوويه اخرى لدينا روسيا لدينا كوريا
الشماليه واظهرت خطوره الموضوع وبالتالي
لم يتمكن الحزب الديمقراطي من التوصل الى
نتيجه الحقيقه وهناك همم استياء على مستوى
الاداره لان ايران لم توافق على العوده
الى الاتفاق
ايضا الانسحاب من اتفاقيه التزمت بها
الولايات المتحده ووقعت عليها اثار جدلا
كبيرا ويربما زعزع الثقه خارجيا لدى البعض
في الولايات المتحده الى اي يعني ما هو
المغزى او ما هي الحكمه التي يراها
الجمهوريه في انسحابات من هذا النوع من من
الالتزام وقعت عليه الدوله
يتعلقوا ببنيتي الاتفاق الاساسيه الرئيس
اوباما لم يشعر بانه يحظى بدعم سياسي من
خلال الاسلوب التقليدي على مستوى مجلس
الشيوخ وبالتالي قام بالعمل على استخدام
صلاحياته من خلال
نقاط الضعف في القانون الرئيسي ترامب قال
انه لن يستفيد من هذه الثغرات القانونيه
وبالتالي ترك الاتفاق اذا بنسبه الى ايران
تود من الولايات المتحده ان تلتزمه بان
الادارات المستقبل لن تنسحب من اي اتفاق
ولكن لا يمكن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ان تقدم هكذا وعود من خلال الاليات
القائمه وفقا للدستور اذا ما وصل الرئيس
الى عمليه معاهده او اتفاقيه التقليديه
يمكن ان تكون ملزمه قانونيه ولكن بالنسبه
الى استخدام
والعقبات والتعليق لسته اشهر هذا لن اي
رئيس مستقبلي يمكنه ان يغير في هذا
الاتفاق
نعم تعليق منك يعني يبدو لي كان الامر
اكثر هو لتعليم اي رئيس ديمقراطي درسا حتى
لا يذهب في نفس الطريقه اكثر من اقتناع
حسب حسب ما سمعته لا اعتقد الامر متعلق
باختلاف الفلسفه بين الحزبين عثمان
الفزلكه الجمهوري او الفلسفه اول نظريه
الحكومه على استخدام القوه العسكريه بشكل
او باخر راي ذلك في اكثر من حرب سواء حرب
العراق في 2003 حرب افغانستان 2002 قبلها
هناك قناع جمهوريه بانه ايران كده كده
هتحصل على سلاح نووي وبالتالي من الافضل
هل يتم توقيع اتفاق معها ويتم اتجاهها
بالخيار العسكري بشكل طبعا هذا يعتبر خيار
مدمر الامريكي ليست فيه رفاهيه تاخذ حرب
جديده في الشرق الاوسط الديمقراطين اقل
مايله اللي مساله القوه هم يكون بانه
اتفاق سيء افضل من لا اتفاق لانه لا اتفاق
يعني فتح المجال على اشياء
او دقيقه و50 ثانيه ما هو المتوقع في
سياسه همم الاداره الامريكيه في الشرق
الاوسط في السيناري
اعتقد انه ستستمر الاداره بنفس الطريقه هي
اداره ضعيفه مرتعشه مهزوزه لم تثب
بالتزاماتها على الاطلاق هناك تراجع عن
معظم الوعود ليس هناك اتفقنا وهو مع ايران
ليس هناك اتفاق سلام بها الفلسطينيون
الاسرائيليين بالعكس دعم لاسرائيلي بشكل
غير محدود هناك دعم للانظمه السلطيه
المستبده سواء في مصر او الامارات او
السعوديه هناك عدم اقتراس بالمنطقه بشكل
انت اتجاه الصين باعتبارها الهدف الرئيس
السيسي ولا ايضا شغال بالحرب مع روسيا
وبالتالي هناك اهتمامات لاداره اكثر بكثير
من منطقه الشرق الاوسط
لدينا ربما دقيقه في 30 ثانيه لكل من كما
ما هي اولويات السياسه الخارجيه
الجمهوريين الديمقراطيه
الى الجمهوريين اعتقد جلسات الاستماع
بنسبه افغانستان مع ايران لتخفيف الدعم
لاوكرانيا هذه نقط ثلاثه بالنسبه الى
الديمقراطيين الدفاع عن حقوق الانسان في
ايران ومحاوله التوصل الاتفاق النووي يمنع
ايران على القنبله النوويه مع العملي على
ادماج اسرائيل في المنطقه والعمل مع
البلدان العربيه ايضا لدعم الفلسطينيين
وتعامل مع اسرائيل بشكل سنوات
في المجلس الامريكي للسياسه الخارجيه
والمسؤول السابق في وزاره الدفاع الامريكي
الدكتور خليل العناني محلل الجزيره سنه
الانتخابات النصفيه شكرا لكم
وبهذا نصل الى نهايه هذه الحلقه من ما
وراء الخبر في تغطيهنا الانتخابات النصفيه
الكونجرس وهي مستمره من واشنطن نلقاكم
باذن الله على راس الساعه المقبله
[موسيقى]